PROFESSOR: So now that we've
discussed prevalence and risk
scenarios, we come to
a very important topic,
which is, when should
you impose the guideline?
Obviously, when the epidemic
is raging at a very high rate,
it feels out of
control, it's spreading,
we want to impose the
guideline that we've discussed,
which limits the indoor
reproductive number
for each space within
some tolerance.
And that would, for example,
give us some number N1
from the safety
guideline, R N less than
epsilon, which is
going to be smaller
than the normal occupancy
of that room for a given
time and all the other factors
that we've been discussing.
But what happens as the
prevalence of infection
goes down.
Generically, there must
be some curve like this.
And we'd like to understand
what is the simplest
reasonable model we can come
up with that can tell us
how to relax the approximation?
So for example, let's think
of a school or a business,
where we typically have a
lot of the same people there
every day, but some others
are coming and going,
or maybe going home and
getting infected and coming in.
So the rate of infection is low.
So we expect typically the
number of infected people
is zero or occasionally one.
And as the prevalence
goes down, then we
start to see that the situation
is getting safer and safer.
So that at a certain point
P1, where we start to say,
you know what we can
actually increase
the occupancy of the space
with everything else held
fixed while still wearing masks.
And then we hit the
normal occupancy.
And you might call that
the new normal, where
we're going about our
business, the room
is filled with the
typical number of people.
Let's say, the classroom
is back to its normal size.
We don't have any remote
teaching going on.
But we're wearing masks
or taking other factors
into account, such as higher
ventilation rates, let's say,
open windows.
But then we continue
lowering the prevalence.
There's a certain
point where we get rid
of those other precautions.
So extra open your windows.
Or more importantly,
the dominant effect
is the removal of the
mask because we know
that's a significant factor.
And then you might call that
back to the real normal,
actually, not the new normal.
Where we are back to full
occupancy and really not
taking any precautions.
That's going to happen at
a rather low prevalence.
But we hope that that
time will eventually come
and hopefully not so
far in the future.
And I mention here a
very important point
we've not talked about
yet in this class
but we should keep in
the back of our minds.
When I talk about
occupancy I'm really
talking about the number
of susceptible people.
We just saw that in the
last couple of boards.
But the number of
susceptible people
are really only those that
are not immune to the disease,
for example, by vaccination.
So as more and more
people become vaccinated,
then this occupancy number
might-- for example,
let's say, as a
typical occupancy
will be at 25 people in a class.
As more and more
people are vaccinated,
the number that we
plug in this formula
here might actually be lower
when we just make decisions
because there are fewer
and fewer susceptible
people that are left.
So that's another very important
factor to keep in mind.
Of course, also, vaccination
has the indirect effect
of lowering the prevalence
that is seen in the population
as we start to stamp
out the epidemics.
So we also have that effect.
So I won't talk about
that any further now
but come back to this
calculation based on the risk
scenario, the second one that
I talked about last time, where
we take into account prevalence
So let's look at the three
different cases here.
So the first one is where we
have restricted occupancy.
This is where we've
decided there's
an N1, which is epsilon
over average beta tau.
So all the physical parameters
are buried in there.
And this is going
to be something
less than the normal
occupancy, N0.
Now what is the tau we
want to think about?
Well, if we have a
school or a business,
this would be the
cumulative time
that people spend
together to the point
where the number of days they
spend together is, let's say,
on the order of a week
would be a reasonable number
to think about.
Because if we write tau is
the typical hours per day.
Time is some kind of
maximum number of days.
This maximum number
of days could
be set by, for example,
the testing frequency.
For example, here at MIT, we are
testing our entire population
at least once a week
in order for anyone,
including myself, to be
admitted to the campus.
And so we are definitely
testing within a week
and catching new
infections at that rate.
It could also be motivated
by the incubation time, which
is the time to show symptoms.
And most people will
remove themselves.
And we know that's around 5.5
days, a typically reported
value.
So again, on the
order of a week.
And there's also, of
course, other ways
that people are removed
or they recover.
So there's removal
and recovery, which
is another way that if
you start to go more than,
let's say, two weeks,
we start to think
an infected person
that didn't get
removed then end up in
the hospital has probably
recovered.
So if we think of a certain
number of days and hours
per day, that
gives a tau that is
going to go into this formula.
And actually, I should also
mention that for simplicity
here, technically this
should be N1 minus 1.
And I can either include that or
not when I do this calculation.
But I'm generally
thinking of N1, which
is going to be bigger than 1.
So think of an
occupancy of 10 people
in a classroom, or
something, might be a limit
that we would be
interested in considering.
But certainly we can put the
1 in there if we want to.
So now let's ask
ourselves, how would we
start to reopen the
space once we've
decided on a safe occupancy
during the greatest
level of restrictions?
So that would then
lead us into a phase
of relaxing restrictions.
And this would
still be with masks.
So keeping in mind that
masks are an essential part
of achieving a
reasonable occupancy when
the pandemic is high and
there's a lot of prevalence.
And that we would only start
to relax occupancy first
before we take away the
suggestion to wear masks.
And that would be
then the last step.
So for relaxing
restrictions, we're
then going to be interested in
the indoor reproductive number
being less than now a
rescaled value, which
would be epsilon over P i Q i
N. And the indoor reproductive
number, remember, is N minus 1.
But it's approximately
N times beta tau.
So I've replaced
again N minus 1 with N
just to get a simpler formula.
And so notice now here, N is
in both sides of the equation.
If I want to solve for
the value N2, which
is this yellow curve
here, I'm actually
going to have to put
the N's on one side
and take a square root.
So my N2 then would
be the square root
of epsilon over beta
tau times P i times Q i.
And remember also,
another approximation
here is that P i is
definitely much less than 1.
We're looking to limit
a very low prevalence.
And so also therefore, Q i
is basically tending to 1
because it's 1 minus P i.
And so that factor is
really not that important.
And notice also, epsilon
over beta tau, that's N1.
So N3 is approximately related
to N1 by the square root of N1
divided by P i.
That's this number here.
So the function prevalence,
this yellow curve,
is 1 over square
root of prevalence.
And one nice thing about
writing it this way
is that I can decide
on a reopening protocol
without actually
redoing my calculation
with all those complicated
variables, including the risk
tolerance epsilon, and
all the factors that
go into beta because
I've lumped them into N1.
What I'm saying here
is that we've already
done a calculation and decided
to impose a certain occupancy
restriction on certain
space based on principles
that we've been
discussing in this course.
But now as prevalence
goes down, according
to the simple formula,
whenever N2 is bigger than 1--
we would use this if
N2 is bigger than N1.
So basically, when
these two curves cross,
as you get a lower prevalence,
you now switch to two
and you'll start increasing.
And you will do that
until you get to N0.
This is the relaxing
restrictions.
So basically, when N2 is bigger,
than we allow this until N2
equals N1.
And that's this
time here, P, P2.
So basically, we start
imposing restrictions at P1.
relaxing restrictions
when the prevalence equals P1.
That would be when
N2 is equal to N1.
And so that would be
when P1 is 1 over N1.
So essentially,
that's when you expect
to find one infected person.
So this is
approximately 1 over N1.
Up here, when you go
below this, you're saying,
well, it's actually unlikely
that during the time tau
we'll even get one
infected person.
And that's when
we start to relax.
So that's the first
crossover point.
And there's a second
crossover point
when this is equal to P2--
sorry, is equal to N0.
That's [INAUDIBLE] P2 is.
And so basically,
P2, which is when
we would hit the
saturation point and that's
when we've reopened
in some sense
to the full normal
situation, that would
be when N2 is equal to N0.
Wait, sorry.
I wrote here N2 equals N1.
Sorry, I meant
when N2 equals N0.
Sorry.
That's the time P2 here,
when N2 is equal to N0,
that's when we cut off.
So this is N0.
And we solve for P i.
You can see that we
get N1 over N0 squared.
So that is the place
where I then switch.
And now I'm going to
cap the occupancy at N0.
So maybe to summarize
here, what I would say
is that the occupancy
should be less
than or equal to N1 for
P i greater than P1.
It'll be N2, which depends
on P i for P i between P1
or P2 and P1.
And then as the
prevalence gets lower,
we go to full occupancy, N0,
when P i is less than P2.
So this is basically this
full curve of reopening.
And then the final
decision to make
is, when do we return
completely to normal
and take away certain
restrictions we've done?
So here I mentioned masks.
We could also include in
this calculation relaxing
other restrictions,
such as maybe not having
the ventilation
on quite so high.
So that would be when
we finally go back
to no restrictions of any kind.
We're back to normal.
So this means no masks, no other
precautions, full occupancy.
So in this case, R N is going
to be less than epsilon over--
well, let's see here.
It's the same as before.
We have this P i, N
that we just looked at.
Or technically. times Q i.
But now we have another
factor, P M squared.
Because compared to
the case with no masks,
we know the bound
in the guidelines.
So the effect of beta just
gets rescaled by P M squared.
So technically
that's in R N here.
But now we have
this extra factor.
You think of it like a
rescaling of epsilon.
And so what that's
going to do for us then
is that there's another curve
that goes like this, which
is just like this one but it's
shifted by a factor P M cubed--
or P M squared, sorry.
Which is like the case where you
had-- so this is like no masks.
It's like the N2 with no masks.
And the other curve
is with masks.
And there's a
rescaling factor, which
really has to do with the
remediation that you've done.
And in this case, P3 would then
just be P M squared times P2.
So if our P M is
a factor of 10%,
let's say, masks are letting
10% of infectious droplets
get through, the P M squared
might be a factor of 100.
So then we would wait
to the prevalence
is 100 times smaller before we
finally allow people to remove
masks and be at full occupancy.
And you could make a
similar calculation
for other types of restrictions.
And in fact, you can
calculate such a curve
for a given room, given
scenario of human behavior
and interventions, such as
filtration or ventilation.
And what the theory allows
you to do is to, of course,
recalculate N1.
And then you can
recalculate N2 as well.
And so you can say, well,
I don't like this curve.
I would like to try to
reopen my school sooner.
How would I do that?
Well, I know that if I
make various interventions,
I can raise the pink curve.
So I could end up somewhere
here, let's just say.
This might be with
safety interventions.
Actually, one such
intervention, by the way,
is masks themselves.
Because if I follow this
curve all the way down here,
there's some curve
down here, which
is no masks, which is the
safety guideline with no masks.
And if I turn on masks, I go up.
But when I make that
intervention, also P2, notice,
scales also like N1.
And so that's actually
moving in this direction.
And so I essentially
move this yellow curve.
And so I'm now
going to say, well,
with a different
set of interventions
I can make the room safer.
And what that does, it gives
me more people in the room.
But it also means
that I change when
I make the decision to reopen.
And in particular,
I can get myself
to full occupancy at
a higher prevalence
because the room is
actually now made safer.
So I note it.
But on the other hand, this
switch here was at 1 over N1.
So this part
shrinks a little bit
as this ultimately goes
up to full occupancy.
So basically, I think compared
to the current situation
or the typical situation
where policymakers are making
decisions based on something
like the six-foot rule
and a somewhat arbitrary
feeling about what is a high
prevalence-- is it 1%, is 0.1%--
and we decide, OK, now
we can close our schools
or reopen our schools or
set the occupancy at half,
the guideline tells you
how to set occupancy
for of the worst case
scenario, when the pandemic is
very prevalent in society.
But now also, through these
kinds of calculations,
we can make rational
decisions about how to reopen.
I'm not advocating necessarily
for the exact formulas
we find on the board here.
But the principles
I'm showing you
could lead to quantitative
and scientifically justifiable
ways of taking a specific
space and a specific usage
of that space and deciding how
to close, as prevalence goes
up, and reopen, as
prevalence goes down,
including ultimately
returning to normal
and removing masks and all
other forms of precaution
as the epidemic disappears.